have you had any colleagues or even
other people that you know casually that
are in other professions such as law
medicine what have you that have
confided in human said I wish I could do
something creative i'm using the left
side of my brain all day long I'm really
screaming out to do something else but I
just can't make that lead for whatever
reason you know it's interesting I get
that all the time it's like you know
they're like doctors knew how do you do
this I mean I've always want to do XYZ
but I don't I can't it's all as an
excuse I can't find the time this is too
challenging that's too challenging or
you know I you know basically you have
to overcome your fear that's that's the
bottom line and in an old professionals
and one way or another I think certain
percentage and feel that way you know
they want to do something maybe it's
music or art or drama or anything it
just boils down to once again you know
how bad you want it and you know are you
good at time management so well seems
like you thrive on challenges a little
bit cuz I mean here you've you've gone
through med school and the residency and
all that and that's draining and
challenging in itself in and maybe so
you're like okay I've done that and then
this is a new challenge that is equally
difficult but in a different way yeah i
agree i think this is this is
monumentally challenging what we're
undertaking here with filmmaking and
acting I felt at some point medical
school was a challenge in you know
becoming a medical doctor definitely was
you know I'm I have a very very stable
practice a lot of you know knock on wood
patients that really like me and I feel
like I've done what I can do and I will
continue in that in that stream but but
it's really not challenging at this
juncture whereas filmmaking definitely
is so I I do i do the thrive on that
well it seems for filmmaking there's not
an Xyz path like with this medicine and
law it seems like you do
these different steps you stay on that
you know pragmatic path and you will
probably get to the end result it's
correct a high probability but with
acting and filmmaking and writing
whatever it's not a clear-cut path it's
not you don't connect the dots and it
works no it's it's really risky so it's
very risky so my hat is off to all those
artists out there that are you know
forging their own path because it it
takes a lot of courage it really does
you know you have to because yeah there
is no clear cup happen and the industry
to a certain degree is closed it's
closed in the sense that it's a lot of
decisions are predicated based on who
you know or who you're associated with
and so forth so to be somebody new or an
outsider it's it's it's tough and you
you you have to you have to go into it
also knowing that you're going to take a
beating so you got to have that mindset
to like it's okay to take a beating like
I'm going to go into this and I may make
a film or do this or do that but you
know some people may like it but a lot
of people are just going to they're
gonna they're going to trash you whether
it's online or with its to your face and
you have to accept that and you have to
have that kind of personality that's not
gonna be like oh my god this person said
this this and that about me you you just
have to say okay you know bring it on
you know dude say what you want to say
but uh you know we're still shooting it
winters dream next to you next season so
you